Why was Lead Added to Paint?
The
use of lead in everyday objects dates back
to the ancient Romans.
They used lead in makeup, as an additive in
food and wine, in pewter dinnerware, and many
other items, including paint.
The inexpensive metal was even used in the
pipes that transported water throughout the
Roman Empire.
Lead continued to be used throughout history
and into modern day.
So it was no surprise that no one thought
twice about adding lead to paint.
But why did manufacturers add the heavy metal
to paint?
What purpose did it serve?
Different lead compounds are added to the
paint as a pigment, creating a specific color
depending on whichever compound is used.
For example, lead (II) carbonate, known as
white lead, makes the paint a white or cream
color and the use of lead tetroxide makes
a bright red paint.
The heavy metal additive also decreases the
amount of time that the paint takes to dry,
makes the paint more durable, and causes the
paint to be more moisture resistant.
This made lead-based paint ideal for use in
homes, on metal exposed to the elements, and
even children’s toys.
Of course, despite the durability of lead-based
paints, they still have that little flaw of,
well, containing lead.
Exposure to the heavy metal can cause numerous
health problems.
High levels of lead present in the body can
lead to convulsions, coma, and death, while
lower levels of the metal can have harmful
effects on the nervous system, brain, blood
cells, and kidneys.
Infants and children are most the susceptible
to lead poisoning and may suffer from physical
and mental development, behavior problems,
and lower IQ levels.
Due to all this, the U.S. government banned
the use of most leaded paints in 1978.
However, it can still be used in houses, but
the government requires that the lead content
be less than 90 parts per million.
As such, today the major source of exposure
to lead paint and lead dust in the United
States continues to be homes built before
1978.
Lead-based paint was popular before that time,
and thus was used in the construction of numerous
homes.
The EPA does note that lead paint that appears
intact is not necessarily harmful.
It can only produce dangerous lead dust if
the paint has been damaged, such as if it
is peeling, being rubbed, or during renovations.